the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
well I want what I'd like to do very
quickly is give you a kind of a brief
account much to skeletal and simple and
simplified of on this conversational
drama
this-this-this the way in which the
Western film becomes a screen on which
American values are projected and on
which American values are tested and in
which we see American values or
assumptions undergoing certain kinds of
transformation certain kinds of certain
kinds of change I don't expect you to
remember these titles or all of these
titles although the ones I talked about
you might think about but and and this
is very far from a complete list of
films it's just a list of highlights but
I won't want to give you a sense of
first that the fit that that the Western
film is at the center of movies at every
phase of the history of the medium and
as we've noted one might argue that one
of the very first films some people have
called it the first narrative film
although that's a slight exaggeration
but one of the most fundamental founding
documents in the history of movies is of
course a Western if not its first story
film one of the earliest narrative films
was was a Western and we might note in
fact that that Western the Great Train
Robbery was also based on itself not on
although it's it is mythologized and and
fiction eyes the Great Train Robbery is
based on it historically on a historical
actuality on a on a robbery that that
was very widely covered in the press
that were about which darn novels were
written with and which became a site of
many films the first one the Great Train
Robbery a more recent one that you may
have heard of if you haven't actually
seen it Butch Cassidy and the Sundance
Kid which tells the same story is bail
it's based on the same gang
until exactly the same story but it's
based on the same gang that was alleged
to have was said to have committed the
Great Train Robbery and that calls our
attention to another factor another
aspect of this what we might call this
story of the mythological aspect of
American cinema and especially of the
Western because it calls our attention
to the fact that the same events may be
narrated again and again and again one
of the points about myth about
collective stories is they're literally
told repeatedly one way to think about
the Western say okay there are
variations but basically it's the same
story of course that's a tremendous
simplification because it's thematic and
moral implications can change radically
but basically the same set of characters
the same setting the same materials told
over and over again obsessively why
would a society do this why it what is
driven what drives us to do this well
one answer is there are pleasures in
familiarity one of the deepest lessons
of the history of literature is that the
romantic and modernist idea of the
artist as a unique individual creating
art AB novo Sooey generous with no
connections to the past is a fantasy and
a delusion in a particular outgrowth of
the romantic and modern period but that
throughout history and throughout most
cultures aren't an especially story
telling has been much much more like the
activities of these popular formats in
which the same kinds of stories are
repeated again and again with with the
variant with with variations and what
one could say that one of the
profoundest resemblances between the
between Shakespeare's time and our own
is the dominance of genre forms in a
popular theatrical environment in
Shakespeare's day it was the popular
theatre that had a similar effect of
trying to define in some sense a notion
of national identity and that's why I
quoted the Renaissance scholar this
afternoon who called Shakespeare's
theatre the theatre of a nation he was
trying to make the same kind of argument
about about the importance of the
centrality of the public theater in
Shakespeare's day that I'm making about
about the movies about the movies in the
20
in the United States in the 20th century
so the Great Train Robbery is a kind of
originating text both for film itself
and for the genre of the Western
Griffiths
the Battle of elder bush ghost was one
of the first longer films I think it was
a half an hour or 45 minutes long it was
a much longer creation than earlier
films and it was one of the first major
examples of large crowds of people met
what mounted people engaged in battle
and that was one of the most astonishing
things the way though it was a
tremendously influential film it it
dramatized battles between cowboys and
Indians in a way that that showed the
power of the medium of film at a very
early stage in 1914 the first movie
dramatization of that novel by Owen
Wister that I mentioned earlier there
was one of also one of the founding
texts in the in the western genre a one
of I mentioned a couple of other films
here one of them jump one of John Ford's
earliest films to demonstrate that I've
got two Ford films listed there to try
to give you a sense of his importance in
the silent era and I list the covered
wagon as a way of showing you that the
genre of the Pioneer story was already
present in the silent era I list the
Iron Horse by Ford as a way of reminding
of how central Ford is but also a way of
reminding you that that story of the
into the the the laying of the railroad
the Intercontinental railroad one of the
central subgenres sub-sub stories
recurring stories in the western begins
in the silent era and I mentioned the
Keaton partly to show you that the genre
had become so widespread that it would
now able it was now so full fully
fledged so fully recognizable even in
the silent era that Keaton was able to
make a comic parody of westerns called
go West with the advent of sound the
first decade of the western movie is
from an artistic standpoint not very
distinguished can you guess why one
primary reason is if you look I say
singing Cowboys
because it was sound the very first
things at all well we're so enamored of
sound we can the novelty of sound is so
remarkable the first thing we'll do is
well it will introduce Cowboys who sing
well and and there were primitive
stories that they told but the stories
were relatively were relatively
superficial the I mentioned in old
Arizona the first sound Western in part
because what was amazing about that film
especially to audiences were literally
the sounds the crackling of the fire the
creaking of the saddles those those
kinds of the noises of the West were
were fascinating to people so the 30s
from an artistic standpoint were not a
very interesting one in terms of the
westerns development nothing be it some
some scholars have argued that the
silent Western was more interesting than
the Western of the of the of the 30s but
they're worth mentioning because they
were very popular and many westerns in
the thirties were used were identified
as what were called be films that is to
say as you may know they and I wish I
had had time to in this course to spend
some some energy talking about what
might be called the movie house culture
how incredibly the the whole society
after about 1930 or nineteen in the
early 30s was permeated by the movies
how every major city had dozens of maybe
even more than an but major of movie
houses showing showing showing films at
all many levels of films recent films
and many older films as well and as I
think I mentioned in an earlier class it
was possible it to to go to third and
fourth were on movie houses showing
movies that were several years old and
to pay something like a quarter in the
morning and go in and watch five or six
movies and I did this as a child in the
late 40s in Brooklyn New York where I
would go into a theater come out I would
go in in the bright morning would come
out it would be dark they were lousy
movies but I was a kid I didn't know any
better and it was a astonishing kind of
kind of culture I should also mention I
call it the movie house culture because
of course I again I haven't had time to
develop this but if you google movie
houses are you what you're what will
immediately appear are a series of
magnificent photographs or images
of movie palaces you could even Google
movie palaces and find the same answer
that now mostly fallen into disuse or
destroyed that that were all over the
country very exotic and remarkable even
the struck the physical structures of
these theaters were exotic and and
exciting these exhibition spaces where
themselves meant to excite you and take
you into a kind of into another world
and partly because of that what they
always offered was a really robust
ticket of offerings you didn't just go
to the movies and watch one movie you
saw at least a double feature the second
feature was often what was called a
b-movie
right a second-rate movie a lower budget
many of them were westerns one reason
for that was because the accoutrements
of the Western are so are so
interchangeable as I mentioned in an
earlier class one of the things they
could do was use stock footage to put
these westerns together very quickly so
they could have a stampede that might
have been appeared in many different
movies but will do the job in this be
Western and so forth and they could use
the same props the same town the same
the same horses and the same costumes
and so forth so for a lot of the 30s the
Western movie was a kind of back up a
kind of a kind of second a second banana
to the primary to the primary film and
in addition there began to develop
especially on Saturday in this movie
house culture a Saturday mornings were
especially for children even Saturday
afternoons they began to develop what
they called matinees which were
intentional intentionally devoted toward
trying to get younger people children
into the into the theaters and they had
a series of sort of B or C westerns some
of which were serials and would continue
from one Saturday to the next I want to
mention my favorite childhood Western
hero whom I still remember and I
remember and what I loved this character
when I was seven and eight years old and
would go to the movies on Saturdays and
oh and see sometimes the serials would
last several weeks a part of it was to
try to get the kids to come back and get
their parents to pay for them to come
back every Saturday so they would always
end with a cliffhanger with a moment of
great tension and you wonder whether
whether the hero and heroine heroine
would survive into the next week but my
fate and there were a whole series of
such films my
favorite such film was a film were a
series of adventure starring a character
named lash Laroux can you guess what
lash LaRue's weapon of choice was yes
the whip a book a bullwhip he never
carried a what a gun what he had this
long bullwhip and he would take this
whip but he got prop like that and it
would snake out across and it would flip
a gun right out of a person's hand or he
could go like this and a little tiny
spot of blood would appear on a person's
nose right it was a unbelievably
ridiculous fantasy and the the lash made
a tremendous beautiful crack when he
brought it back but he was obviously a
figure of childhood fantasy but he was a
tremendous was a tremendously memorable
film and and again it was it was there
was no pretensions towards psychological
seriousness or even thematic density in
these in these in these westerns but
they were but they permeated the culture
they were part of the experience of
childhood so children in the society
would grow up watching these children's
versions of westerns and then they would
graduate to the more adult Lester's I
don't want to call it a form of
brainwashing because that's much too
negative a way of describing the way in
which these story forms shape our
understandings or help to shape our
understand and I don't mean that human
beings are completely programmable
creatures so they go and look at a movie
and they become robots following what
the movie said but what I am saying is
that the way these kinds of stories
permeated the society helped to shape
America's Americans understanding of
their natures of what the social fabric
was like of what masculinity was of what
femininity was of what families were of
what the relations among the races were
of what American history was about what
the Founding story of America is about
what the central organizing values of
our culture are all of those things are
dramatized either explicitly or
implicitly in movies and because the
movies were so central through the 20th
century they were one of the central
ways in which the belief system the
values of American society were
promulgated dramatized rehearsed and in
some ways altered and changed
the classical age of the Western film is
often said to be the period in of the
1940s and this is really the moment when
the Western as an artistic form begins
to come into its own although it also
still carries IDIA logical or thematic
baggage we might not want to embrace or
celebrate so remember it's an ambivalent
thing here I'm asking you to respect the
artistry of these films but I'm also
asking you to do something mature and
grownup which is be skeptical about the
meanings that are embodied in some in
what are sometimes very artful of movies
and we call it the Classical Age in part
because a certain kind of much more
ambitious intellectually powerful and
artistically organized Western begins to
appear dominated but not completely by
the great director John Ford who's one
of whose masterpieces you're going to
see in a few minutes the the age
probably begins in 1939 the same year
that the integrated musical begins with
what was the film we mentioned it last
week The Wizard of Oz right the in which
color is introduced for the first time
well here the genre of the Western comes
into its own really in the in roughly in
the same year in a film that stars John
Wayne who was the one of the iconic
stars of the American Western and
directed by John Ford his favorite
director a director who did other things
but who was noted especially for the for
his remarkable for his remarkable
westerns for Wayne had had him a career
in the movies ten years before that but
in stagecoach for the first time he
became a major star the film made him a
star and stagecoach is an interesting
film because it's more it articulates or
formulates one of the great subgenres
within the category of the Western and
this is I don't know exactly what to
call it it's the story it's a story in
which you have a group of unlike people
who are traveling usually by stagecoach
or in some others sometimes it can be by
train who are be set without
unexpectedly by some kind of danger
usually an attack by Indians and well
and then the the uneasy community that
is forced upon the one they have to
defend themselves reveals various
aspects of human nature and of human
society
the film stagecoach is a classic
instance of that in which the John Wayne
character gets on a stagecoach as it's
making a making a void of as it's making
a journey across a bleak western
landscape through Indian Territory
and he's a kind of ambiguous figure the
way in this film the Wayne character
perhaps an outlaw but and and the
respectable people who were in the
stagecoach a banker who actually won a
character who's actually embezzling
money and is trying to get away although
no one knows
he hasn't revealed it at the time it
comes out in the course of the film and
a series of other sort of characters
with interesting backgrounds that emerge
when they're when the when the
catastrophe descends upon them and of
course what happens is the ambiguity of
the way in character the fact that he
has a kind of connection to the two
lawlessness turns out to be one of the
great virtues that he has because of
course he becomes their the primary
defender of the group when they are
beset by savage Indians and then I've
listed again let me remind you again
I've just picked these are just
highlights remember that remember what
we said as nearly 30% of all films made
before the during the studio era were
western movies and these are among the
highlights and from from the titles you
can see them sort of recurring sub
subgenres that occur Billy the Kid in
1941 the film directed by David Miller
there's a preoccupation without laws
there number of films about Billy the
Kid a number of films about Jesse James
and about the and AB and about the
gunfight at the OK Corral the film the
1946 film My Darling Clementine by a
ford's famous film starring Henry Fonda
is one of six movies made about the
gunfight at the OK Corral and think of
what that says to us right what does a
myth do it tells the same story again
and again and again each of those six
films is in in many ways different for
in significant ways each film is
different from another the other film
even though the basic information or at
least the basic situation is the same
and in fact some in some versions of the
film in some versions of that account of
the account of the OK Corral the Wyatt
Earp and the eart brothers fight against
the Clanton brothers in
versions the Earp's in the classic
versions in the version My Darling
Clementine in 1946 by Ford the Earp's
are heroes and Wyatt Earp is a great
American is a noble American hero who
who defends a town against anarchy and
evil the Clanton's are entirely evil but
in later revisionist versions of the
same story herp is a herp and his
brothers are seen as you as as as
arrogant officials who are trying to
control gambling and prostitution in the
town of Tombstone and and the Clanton's
not seen as noble but are seen
essentially as rivals of the of the
herbs not necessarily as inferior evil
characters and such a perspective of
course profoundly changes our
understanding of what the gunfight at
the OK Corral represented well
interesting that that uh and and and
deeply revealing that so many Westerns
have been repeated that did not mean the
same story told again and again and so
so the story the fact that the gunfight
at the OK Corral was repeated at least
six times in feature-length films
there were also television versions of
the OK Corral event adding to the number
except is it is a dramatic example of
what we might call this mythological
function that or this forum function
this discourse space function that that
the that John reforms in general and the
western movie in particular have I've
already mentioned Red River in my
earlier discourse about about Howard
Hawks and I want to just remind you that
that great director of screwball comedy
was also one of the great directors of
masculine adventure films including what
many people think is one of the great
westerns of all time Red River and Red
River is an interesting sub 0 as well
it's a cattle drive western many
westerns are about cattle drives right
but this one also adds a complex a very
interesting complexity because there's a
kind of oedipal drama and acted out
between our John Wayne faith the John
Wayne figure recurring figure in so many
westerns and a younger man played by the
great actor Montgomery Clift who who
plays a kind of a surrogate son to the
John Wayne character of course conflict
develops and and and the the the rivalry
between father and son is a kind of
fundamental subplot in in
in that remarkable in that remarkable
Western one other thing I should say
about the 40s period I call it the
Classical Age primarily for this reason
I sort of didn't name this and forgive
me for not mentioning this earlier again
we're talking about the period just
before during and after the Second World
War right the United States feels itself
to be beleaguered right
the world is beleaguered in a way it's a
net that that outer reality also helps
to explain why the Western of the 1940s
would be essentially a kind of
celebration of American power a
celebration of American Empire a
celebration of American know-how
incompetence in the wilderness because
by analogy the Western is a kind of
story of American success of American
conquest and this was one one might
think of it as a story that America
needed to tell itself during a period
during the period of so the war the
second world war is a great
reinforcement to the to the way in which
in the Classical Age of the American
Western were telling the the film the
western film is basically telling an
heroic story is celebrating the conquest
of the West and is seeing the white
man's settlement of the West in
relatively unambiguously admirable terms
celebrating the the courage and the
resilience and the physical prowess of
the pioneers and the and the and the
great noble gunfighters who tamed the
West for us but by the 1950s this
confidence has begun to wane part of it
is look the war has been over for a
significant time um the American society
is is a you know in in a peacetime boom
which is going to build through the 50s
and it's also a period in which a
certain kind of it this was of course
the period of my childhood right I was
10 years old in 1950 and I remember it
vividly in fact saw some of the films
that are listed here in the theaters for
the first time so I say I mention that
to you just to remind you that in fact
what we're talking about is not ancient
history at all because I actually
experienced some of the films on this
list in my own actual lifetime when they
were originally shown in the theaters
and although I am it infinitely old
compared to you guys I'm still a you
know a vigorous functioning human being
so within my lifetimes memory many of
these films were contemporary and it's
important to realize how close we are in
fact to this to this to the to these
times so and so the but one of the
things that began to appear in the 1950s
was a kind of skepticism about the
social arrangements in the society at
first they were very modest and mild
there was in the 1950s for example what
came to be called a generation gap in
which older and younger in which they
was thought to be a kind of distance
between older and younger people and
there was a great concern in the 1950s
for for alienated youth and juvenile
delinquency which was a was a was a was
a what a great catchphrase and some of
the films of the 1950's dramatized that
for example the film the left-handed gun
in 1958 starring Paul Newman directed by
Arthur Penn is a story really about it's
a it's a Billy the Kid story right
Newman plays the Billy the Kid type
character but he plays a young boy he
plays a really a post-adolescent and you
can feel that what's partly being
dramatized there are are teenage angst
there are and what also begins you can
in 1952 the film High Noon a fragment of
which I will show in next week's lecture
when we talked about McCabe and mrs.
Miller to do a kind of contrast with a
classical Western and a McCann a post
classical Western that that film
introduces certain kinds of contemporary
political concerns many people see High
Noon as a parable about the McCarthy era
Senator Joseph McCarthy and the fear of
the paranoia about communism and the
anti-communist hysteria of the late 40s
and early 1950s when the Cold War was
just getting getting powerfully started
and High Noon is a kind of parable about
a good man who turns to a sheriff who
turned played by Gary Cooper one of the
great iconic heroes of masculinity and
of the classical Hollywood era along
with John Wayne and Cooper plays a
sheriff who has brought peace to the
town he's been a sheriff for many years
and I'm on his wedding dais marrying a
Quaker a Quaker woman he's giving up his
gun because the Quaker woman
played by Grace Kelly you'll remember
her from the Hitchcock film although he
or she plays a western heroine she's a
Quaker she he's putting down his gun to
join his wife and and on his wedding day
a man that he sent to jail is coming
back by the noonday train to to take his
revenge so the sheriff spends the early
part of the film going around to the
townspeople a town that owes its life to
this great heroic sheriff saying help me
I'm going to be attacked by Frank Miller
and his gang no one will help him he's
left on his own he has to stand by
himself because the town is too cowardly
and it's a it's it's a it's a parable of
the cowardice of people who deserted
it's a in some sense a kind of left-wing
argument if it's a parable about the
cowardice of people who wouldn't stand
up for folks who were attacked by
Senator McCarthy and and and other
anti-communist for being disloyal so
that certain kinds of political meanings
begin to skeptical political meanings
begin to creep in and the society that's
dramatized in in High Noon is hardly an
admirable Society they the the the the
Western culture may have created a town
and the town has a church which and they
have a meaning in the church in in the
film what he goes to the the day it's a
Sunday and you could hear the church
bells and he goes to the church and he
asks for help from the congregation and
they won't do it they're too cowardly
and so it's a so it's a parable about
cowardice and about and about and about
political dysfunction and about communal
disloyalty very also already by the
1950s when a little bit before the the
Hollywood era is is it's completely
completely concluded or been obliterated
Hollywood Hollywood dominance is still
significant in the night in the 1950s
the Western has begun to change it's
begun to reflect social changes as well
as thematic or ideological changes that
have to do with the way the society is
altering after the Second World War and
a number of the films that I've listed
there do that kind of thing and one
could also
in this in this listing of so-called
adult westerns a greater emphasis on
psychological themes on the conflict
between individuals one very powerful
and interesting instance of that is a
film in 1967 directed by Martin Ritt
starring the great Paul Newman in which
Newman plays half a half white half his
Spanish or half Indian character I think
he's an Indian a Native American and
it's a film it's a parable about racism
the Newman character is angry at both
the white and and the Native American
society he doesn't fit in any place but
it's especially a parable about his
exclusion about about the about about
the Paul Newman characters exclusion
from white society and about and about
the power of racism by the time we get
to the end of the 1960's we're beginning
to get films that have a kind of violent
quotient a violence quotient that's
different and bloodier and more
disturbing than the violence we saw
during the Classical Age and we
especially associate this form of
violence with the director Sam Peckinpah
whose film in 1969 the Wild Bunch takes
a number of actors who had been stars in
classic westerns and brings them back in
a Western what that sort of is much
darker and shows these older men as and
that there first of all their age is
emphasized their sort of doddering
around they're my age right they're in
they're in their late 60s or early 70s
and they they don't seem as vigorous as
they should be for one thing there's I
think they're even scenes in which their
nearsightedness of one of the characters
is dramatized right but but they're aged
and trembling this is only a part of
their unheroic dimensions and and we can
see that the the film the film although
it celebrates the these heroes in a
certain way the celebration is cankered
it's it's it's it's damaged it's a
damaged kind of celebration there's a
sense that these men are past their
prime
that they're sleeping with women who are
far too young with them and that and
there's something kind of disgusting
about that we see that one of the actors
of an older and all their figure Robert
Ryan there
gifted actor who was in many many
westerns and other films in the
Classical Age of Hollywood plays an
agent and very power very effective
gunfighter there's a terrible scene in a
brothel where he's she's not a teenager
but there's a woman surely thirty years
younger than he who becomes his bed mate
and there's something sour about the
scene intended I think by the director I
mean you can feel it it's as if it's as
if the Western values have begun to
congeal and sickened even before we get
to the what I'm calling the anti Western
and of course in the late 60s there also
begins to emerge the phenomenon I talked
about earlier this afternoon how the
Italians start making westerns putting
them in in Italian and they and they
find locations in Europe that replicate
American deserts and and so forth and
the the Italian westerns especially
those that are associated with Sergio
Leone have a kind of dark existential
almost nihilistic flavor and one of the
things that that Leone did that was very
subversive he took characters act at
American actors who were associated with
great heroic idealistic roles in
American westerns of of the 40s and 50s
and he put them into westerns in which
they played evil villains murderous
criminals who who had no compassion or
pity for any of their victims and
there's something shocking about seeing
noble Henry Fonda who played young Abe
Lincoln in John Ford's movie and played
so many wonderful heroic figures
including including Wyatt ER including
Wyatt Earp in in My Darling Clementine
suddenly turned into a to a to a stone
killer and that kind of reversal
anticipates what happens in the 1970s
now and of course what happens in the
70s partly again a consequence of
transfer transformations in American
society I'll talk a bit about the
cultural history of the 70s next week
when I talk about film in the 70s in a
systematic way but suffice it to say for
now that what goes on there is a a
series of westerns begin to appear that
are permeated by the anti-establishment
value
news of the counterculture that are
permeated by the anti-war movement right
because the era right of the Vietnam War
of tremendous fissures in American
society its I'll talk more about this
next week so I don't want to repeat
myself so it's a period in which
American culture is it's conflicted and
and divided in a horrific way
and the westerns we begin to reflect
that and in fact the old heroic
enterprise of of the classic westerns of
the 1940s and early 50s is suddenly
transformed in a series of anti westerns
or dissenting westerns in 1970 Ralph
Nelson makes a film called soldier blue
in which the American cavalry the the
the heroes of so many films including a
trilogy of films by John Ford made in
the late 40s called the cavalry trilogy
right in which John Wayne is in one of
those films at least one of those film
celebrates the American the blue the
blue suited cavalry of the of the
western era in Ralph Nelson's film the
the soldier the American soldiers are
the enemy they're there it's it's almost
and they they they commit atrocities
that some scholars have associated with
the me lie atrocities in Vietnam and the
sort of Western has become a screen on
which America's anxieties about the
Vietnam War have been projected why
would the Western work so well for this
one answer is what I've been saying all
along about the power of genre and the
power of repetition look if I thing is
repeated again and again and again it
looks familiar when it's so familiar
what happens it licenses something
disturbing because it's so because the
genres it seems on the surface to
contain so many familiar reassuring
elements those very elements of
reassurance enable the exploration of
disturbing or uncertain or or
problematic materials and that's one of
the real and of course because any any
note not any one of these films would
have nothing like the power they
actually have if they existed
individually but it's because they're
part of this long conversation that goes
back to the earliest days of movies that
they have the power that they have
in 1971 the film starring Dustin Hoffman
little big man is
another such film in which it's the
Indians the Native Americans who are the
heroes and the little big man of the
title is played by Dustin Hoffman he's a
Native American who has survived Indian
massacres and lives to tell the story
till and of course in 1971 the film
you'll see next week that will embody
these principles Robert Altman's McCabe
and mrs. Miller the Western doesn't
disappear it doesn't completely die but
it falls it falls away as time continues
in part I think because our increasingly
urbanized society after the 1950s became
less and less amenable the Western
became less and less less and less but a
credible or valuable or or it became
harder and harder for most Americans to
identify with aspects of the Western
that's one reason and and other genres
begin to take over
especially the science fiction genre and
one of the things you might think about
if you think about the rise of science
fiction in from ninety from the 50s and
60s init's and then especially from the
70s and Beyond and especially the rise
of the science fiction film is you can
begin to see a hybridization going on in
which many of the features of the
Western are superimposed on a science
fiction format and Man Thing you I'm
sure you can think of many such examples
of science fiction films that borrow
from and utilize Western conventions so
that's one feature that be there are
certain kinds of hybridization in which
some of the features of a Western begin
to appear in other genres but this but
of course the Western because of the
resonance of the form it continues to be
a space in which gifted directors are
able to make statements about the nature
of American society and exactly again
because of the familiarity of it and
because of the long history of the
discourse we associate the themes and
discourses we associate with the Western
every new Western is always implicitly
in a conversation with its ancestors and
we have in the 1990s a series of
interesting films some of you may have
seen them Clint Eastwood's Unforgiven
Kevin Costner's Dances with Wolves and
two more versions of the Wyatt Earp
story tombstone and Wyatt Earp just a
couple of titles
more recent times in 2007 3:10 to Yuma a
remake of an earlier film this that I
that I that I listed earlier 1957 film
if you compare those two films you can
see how much more violent
how much more anarchic how much less
idealizing and romanticizing the Western
has become the assassination of Jesse
James by the Coward Robert Ford a
wonderful title which replicates exactly
the title of one of those dime novels
appeared in 2007 and let me mention two
astonishingly rich and interesting
examples from television television by
the lip by the 80s and 90s is already a
rival to the movies has really replaced
the movies in many ways in terms of
complexity and richness as well as
having replaced the movies somewhat
earlier as our consensus form as our
central form but two films especially
one the famous that the well-known
miniseries Lonesome Dove made from the
Larry McMurtry novel one of the best
television one of the best westerns ever
made a wonderful multi-part story
utilizing the serial nature of
television to tell a Western with an
expansiveness that the movie screen can
allow but that the conditions of
exhibition in the movies do not allow
right you can't go back to the movie you
can't watch a movie for six hours or
eight hours and it's much less
convenient to go once a week for for two
hours for seven or eight weeks to see
the same story television is a perfect
environment for that in that sense the
small the reduced visual scale of
television is what keeps it keeps the
television from being really as powerful
and medium for the Western as the movies
are but still great film great westerns
are made and the greatest of all
television westerns one of the great
westerns one of the greatest westerns
ever made is the ongoing series David
Milch is great series Deadwood that
appeared on HBO from 2004 to 2006 was
abruptly cut off by the HBO bosses in my
view it's the equivalent in the history
of television to the story of what
happened to the last laugh in which the
in which the producers damaged a work of
art but even in its damaged form
Deadwood is one of the most remarkable
westerns ever
made and it is deeply deeply deeply
anarchic dissenting skeptical about
human values and about and about motives
it's the opposite of an ideal izing
Western it sees the West as emerging
from from Western society as emerging
from human greed from entrepreneurial
insan' viciousness from-from fear it it
it from a historical and intellectual
standpoint it's a far more persuasive
understanding of how history evolves I
think than earlier idealizing forms a
deeply disturbing and powerful text so
the Western remains even in its vestige
old condition even though it's now faded
it's no longer as central a format for
an urbanized and Technology eyes society
remember the United States before the
Second World War was most mostly in
rural society we only became a suburban
and an urban a fully urban society after
the Second World War and the growth of
the suburbs is the great event of course
after the Second World War and what so
that so that more and more of the
population found rural spaces alien and
didn't grow up in big spaces and didn't
and and couldn't identify in the same
way with the Western story and the
conditions of experience the conditions
of life in the United States underwent a
transformation that made the Western a
more much more of a of a of a
traditional a vestige of voice a
vestigial form than a central one and
weakened strace the progress of that of
the film's movement of the Western
genres movement from the center to the
more marginal or peripheral parts of the
society in this history that I've
briefly shown you I have a few things to
say about John Ford can you put him up I
won't spend a lot of time on this but I
want to mention some things about him
the the this is a this is a list of his
of some of his of some of his
significant films not all that I've
listed here are westerns but you can see
a number of them are he begins in the
silent era he continues robustly through
the sound era being one of the great
directors of the sound era
and and you can see you know a film like
young mr. Lincoln is is is not quite a
western drums along the Mohawk half of
Western he made other films that were
that were not westerns but the Western
was his signature form it was a very
unpretentious man and when he when he
was introduced to people he often said
hello I'm John Ford I direct westerns I
make westerns he didn't say I'm a film
director he didn't say I must see the
east he didn't say I'm an artist in the
movies he said I'd make westerns and I
like the unpretentious nosov that of
that of that quality in him he was the
13th child of Irish immigrants born in
Maine his father was a saloon owner and
at the age of 18 in 1913 after high
school he followed his brother Jack to
Hollywood when he was where he went
where his brother was a writer and a
director he began to work in his
brothers films as a prop man and a stunt
man and a bit actor he played a Ku Klux
Klansmen in The Birth of a Nation so
he's he's a man who's right the first
what's why his birth of a nation
important the first feature-length film
in the United States DW Griffith and and
chose Ford's connection to the history
and centrality to the history of the
American film and he he directed his
first film in 1917 which was a bet it
was a bank robbery western and he in
that year he directed his first feature
the film I listed earlier on the list on
our on our little history of the Western
straight shooting and then a series of
films through through the through his
through his career that 30 silent films
by 1921 nearly all of which have been
lost so he was a very prolific director
in the silent era and finally at the end
of his career he would had had directed
more than a hundred films over 60 sound
features 14 westerns of which at least 5
to 7 are among the greatest westerns
ever made
III won't single out any particular
films here except
indicate that by the time we get to the
late 50s to the searchers the man who
shot Liberty valance Cheyenne autumn
seven women a new kind of skepticism has
entered into the idealizing and heroic
tendencies that were characteristic of
Ford's work in his earlier westerns and
one of the reasons that the film you're
going to see tonight is so central is
that it may be Ford's most profoundly
ambivalent Western the the Western in
which his impulse to celebrate the
heroic qualities of these pioneers and
and and the resilience and survival
qualities that were required to live in
these in to survive in these
environments or there are very central
but but he's begun to recognize begun to
acknowledge what his earlier films had
not acknowledged the moral complexities
of the idea that the whites should come
and take land away from the Indians that
the you know he's become to realize that
the settlement of the West is not an
unambiguous triumphal story but a more
complex and morally ambiguous tale and
that moral ambiguity is at the heart of
the film you're going to see tonight The
Searchers it has a damaged hero as
you'll recognize it's probably John
Wayne's greatest role John Wayne he
plays a character named Ethan in the
film and it's interesting maybe Wayne
didn't fully understand how how
ambivalently
the central character is treated because
he named his firstborn son Ethan it's a
strange thing because the Ethan that
John Wayne plays here is not really an
attractive person he has qualities that
we admire and that John Wayne and that
at John Ford surely admires you know
he's he's tremendously good with a gun
he's deeply knowledgeable about how to
survive in the West he knows a
tremendous amount about the Native
Americans he can ride a horse like a
like a rodeo rider right he's brave
beyond belief but he's also as we
discover a racist there's a danger all
the way through the film that he may
murder the young girl he's trying to
find he's searching for a young girl and
there's some question all the way
through the film and what his motive is
whether he wants to find her to kill her
or whether he wants to find her to
rescue her why does he want to kill her
part of his damage it the implication of
the early part of the film is that he
not just the implication the fact is he
come in the early part of the film we
discover that he probably thought that
he fought on the Confederate side of the
war so he's coming home a loser and
there's an implication very early as
you'll see that he committed various
kinds of crime that he rode with outlaws
Durand and and and and that some of the
loop that he has taken from the war may
be ill gained right that he didn't that
that is that he was a that he's a bitter
and unhappy war veteran who feels that
his side lost so he enters the film
bitter as a as an embittered and damaged
person as the film continues we
recognize that in fact this family he's
returned to his brothers family and his
brother's wife and his nieces and
nephews as that there's a complexity
there because of the looks that he
exchanges with his brother's wife you
realize not that they've ever had an
affair or anything but that they had
loved each other first and that the wife
maybe still loves the John Wayne
character even though she'll never act
on it watch how that happens because
there not a word of dialogue is spoken
but for dramatizes this almost heavy
handedly it's not a novel ambiguous even
though the John John Wayne's the
character playing John Wayne's brother
is completely oblivious to this but the
audience knows it so he's an embittered
damaged a partial figure even from the
beginning and then as they as the story
goes on we discover other qualities in
him that make us nervous
I've said for example that he may be a
racist and we don't know why whether
he'll kill or save the person he's after
the person that the the the film
involves an Indian attack in which in
which the John Wayne characters Nate
nice is taken in by Indians and the most
of the film is the John Wayne character
and his sidekick attempt to recover the
stolen woman right and all his nice
right she's stolen as a child but it
takes many years before they recover her
and by the time they recover she's a
young woman and she's been the wife of
an Indian brave a character named scar
who was really ultimately a kind of
double of the of the of the hero in
certain ways as we as we come to
recognize when we when we look when we
look closely at the film and
and his search for this girl is
ambiguous to us because he's so against
he hates Indian so much it's a form of
the number when the film is taking place
during the civil rights era right so
that we can read John Wayne's hatred of
Indians as a form of the racism of in
the anti anti african-american prejudice
that is that is being dramatized that is
being fought over in in in the civil
rights movement in the United States in
the 50s and 1960s so it's a kind of
metaphor for what's happening there and
we're not sure whether the John Wayne
character is actually going to save her
or kill her when he finds her because
she's been polluted by her connection to
an Indian it's about Miss you know he's
and and this theme it's not it's not
hidden because because the the John
Wayne character sidekick his cut is
really worried about this and even
accuses him of this and someone so he's
a damaged and ambiguous character there
are things about him we admire but the
things about him that disturb us and at
the very end of the film in in what is
one of the most famous images of in in
John Ford's work we get a shot of John
Wayne from the back
he's been excluded from the community in
a way we see him from the back he's
standing like this we we see him who in
our aperture through a doorway and he
grabs his he makes this kind of a
gesture a gesture of vulnerability in
which we and he's standing isolated and
alone there's a sense in which he's
still this this this extraordinary hero
has been in some sense excluded from the
very community that he helped create in
part because he has so because he's
because he doesn't deserve to be part of
it he's dead he's damaged he's imperfect
but but also because of the natural the
natural or the in the mythic logic of
the Western in which the savior figure
is so tainted by the savagery he saved
us from that he can't be included in the
community that he's helped to create so
it's a very clear example of this of
this Western pattern but it's morally
complicated because it comes at such a
late stage and because by this time for
and himself has begun to reflect on the
implications of the much more simplistic
stories he had told earlier in his
career the setting of the film is
important to talk of
because it is filmed in a place that
came to be called John Wayne's own
special theater his own stage set
Monument Valley in Arizona other
directors have worked in that place but
they always it always feels as if
they're plagiarizing John Ford he made
at least nine films in Monument Valley
and you'll see the power of that space
the looming rock formations the sense
you have all the way through the film
that they're human habitations are
minimal doe minimal structures that
could be blown away in a second and that
that are dwarfed in compact in
comparison to the to the rock formations
and the grandeur of the gigantic natural
phenomena that we see around us the
human being seems small and human the
human habitation seemed marginal and far
from permanent in this in this world of
grandeur of what we might call inhuman
grandeur so the setting is important the
plot very important to realize that it
embodies two separate important kinds of
stories the first the founding story
what I've talked about earlier today the
idea that this is the a family how a
culture is founded right you create a
society against warring elements rescue
it from the wilderness from and from and
from savage not just savage nature but
from but from but but but from savage
antagonists the American Indians who
don't want to give up their land and who
are in until we get to this film in John
Ford's films mostly had been figured as
anarchic figures of pure evil they
hadn't been humanized they've been seen
as part of nature right in this film not
so there's a sympathy for the Indians
that enters this film that helps to
explain its complexity and its richness
the second great story is the captives
tale one of the central and earliest
forms of American narrative the captives
tale that is told here is based on a
true story a woman named Cynthia Ann
Parker was abducted at the age of nine
by Comanches in Texas in 1836 a novel
was written about that event by Alan
LeMay and
much after the event and Ford's film is
based on the novel one of the ironies is
that the real Cynthia and chase chose
her come Cynthia Ann chose her Comanche
husband over her Anglo relatives when
she was rescued she didn't want to
unlike the son like the novel and unlike
what happens in yeah in the film and I
mentioned this in part to remind you of
the sort of romanticizing tendencies of
the American Western but still captives
tales stories of white people especially
white women captured by Indians and
raised by Indians were a staple whereas
were a staple of the popular culture uh
from long before the history of movies
and the move this movie like other
movies dramatizes a version of that
captives tale the structure of the film
is worth calling attention to in part
because it's ambiguous one way to
organize the plot I mean the structure
of the of the of the film is to
recognize that there are seven moments
in the film that we might think of as
like chapters or bookmarks and if you
watch for these moments they're all it's
also as structurally significant device
if you watch for these moments you'll be
able to follow the you'll recognize that
the film is progressing because it's
it's it's time frame is intentionally
ambiguous for reasons I'll hint that in
a moment
and these seven moments all involve a
similar kind of shot the camera looks
through a doorway or an opening out into
a rectangle of receding light the very
opening of the film has one such shot
and again and at seven different moments
in the film we see a shot from inside an
interior space from a dark interior
space and we look out through a doorway
you might ask yourself why in a film
that celebrates and that dramatizes the
immense expansiveness of the Western
environment Ford would give us images so
would such self-conscious obvious images
that that first of all refer to each
other so you think about what took what
when they occur in the film but why he
would so intentionally restrict the
visual range of what's available make
you feel confinement why does he do that
one possibly that I might leave this for
your section to think about why he
doesn't one of one effect is surely to
make you even more
aware of how expansive the outside is
because you are in the outside for a lot
of the time by confining your vision in
this way
it's a it's a reminder of how much
bigness is out there but there are other
reasons as well that were for why the
perspective would be restricted to these
sort of aperture shots in any case there
are seven of them through the film and
they mark the progress of the film the
reason that the film is so hard to
follow is in part that the time frame is
weird and I'll come to that in a second
there is one turning point in the film
that I want to mention to you that you
should watch for it's a moral turning
point or a psychologically important
turning point because it's a moment in
the film where the sympathy of the
viewer is shifted is radically
transformed it occurs fairly about
midway through the film where the John
Wayne character and his sidekick Martin
Pawley come riding down a not quite a
mountain but a law promontory through
heavy snow in the summer the weather in
the film is interesting and powerful
what's one of the ways you can feel time
passing their winters and summers go by
you can feel the seasons passing but
you're not clear how much time goes by
by the end of the film you know many
years has gone by at least 10 years
because the young girl who was stolen
away in the beginning is a young woman
at the end of the film played the old
adult played by the actress Natalie Wood
a very successful and and and important
actress of the of the 50s and 60s and
and so she's a grown woman by the end so
that we know that a significant amount
of time has gone by but it isn't clear
as the story is going on exactly how
much time has gone by and and that
ambiguity is important
the turning point occurs as they're
coming down this hill the horses are
almost up to their shoulders in snow and
they come riding down this hill into a
village in Indian village a Native
American village and it's a Native
American village that's in smoking ruins
it has been decimated by American
cavalry and they go into one of the
teepees and they find dead in the tepee
and an Native American woman a [ __ ]
named look
who had been following them and we've
gotten to know her and the Martin Pawley
character the secondary character the
sidekick says to John to the John Wayne
care who I did they have to kill look
she didn't do anything and it's a moment
in which the butchery of the white
soldiers is dramatized in which your
sympathy turns entirely away from the
official American government account of
the West towards something else and in
the very next scene something amazing
happens it's easy to miss because it
happened so quickly but it's very
important morally to the film we have a
scene in which we see three Indian
chieftains standing in their captives
standing in in in blankets looking on as
another group of Native Americans
Indians are being essentially herded
into a into a compound into a hospital
type building and and we can and and
they're being herded as if they're sort
of cattle or sheep or you know not fully
human and you can see there's no common
no no dialogue but you can see the the
the the sadness and the and the and the
unhappiness in regret in the eyes of
these of these sturdy Chiefs as they
look upon it and what happens in that
moment is that the film's perspective
has become that of the Native Americans
and the audience's perspective has
become that as well and they're so and
so the effect of these moments coupled
with many other things in the film some
of which I've mentioned some of which
I've not about the ambiguity of the John
Wayne characters nature come together
here and this is this is a moment in
which something of the complexity of the
Western story is being acknowledged by
the text right no longer are we getting
a kind of simple celebration of these
Western values something much more
ambiguous and morally complex is
happening here a critique of those
values is being embedded in this
apparently classic Western and it's one
of the reasons it's such a remarkable
film I'll conclude now I apologize for
running over the title itself terrifies
some of the ambiguity of the movie what
are they searching for I said before
that the time frame of the film is
confusing and it's not just that even
the setting of the fit even the setting
the Monument Valley setting comes to
seem almost like a lunar landscape of
we're finished with the film there's a
sense there's a sense that the quest
goes on forever that they begin to lose
a sense of why they're doing it after
all so much time has gone by she's lived
with the Native Americans all this time
what's the point of the rescue even we
might we might think right and the fact
that that the quest has gone on for such
a long time but we're but but it becomes
more and more unclear why the search is
going on what the what the purpose of
the search is there's a kind of
ambiguity in it that that is is is is
deeply is deeply disturbing and deeply
troubling and of course at the of the
the the the sense we have at the end of
the film that the search it is concluded
but almost until the very end we're not
sure whether the John Wayne character is
going to save or murder the object of
his quest and there's also the sense
that even after he's done it what has
been gained
it's very so there's a there's a deep
ambiguity at the end at the end of the
movie as there is a deep ambiguity
surrounding the alleged heroism of the
John Wayne character so what one of the
reasons I emphasize these ambiguities
and complexities is as a way of
stressing the fact that even before we
get to the era of what I'll call the
anti western or the descending Western
the classic Western itself has reached a
level of complexity and maturity
embodied especially in this film and
others that we might cite from the 1960s
in which a kind of self-consciousness
about the assumptions that lie behind
and animate this Central American form
have already come to the surface and are
being confronted by our best directors
in our best films good night
you